my eyelashes look like whiskers I would
say I look him like him about to go out
for an audition - cats right now we've
been dating almost four years and we
also have been living together for a few
years we've been dating for a year and a
half we do not live together to me she
seems like the quintessential morning
person I hate mornings I have like a 650
alarm a 655 alarm and a 702 alarm I go
to a bootcamp class and then I go back
to the townhouse uh okay you're
forgetting a couple things I've caught
in you several times sitting in your car
eating chips I think she doesn't enough
that she should consider that part of
her schedule and then I put a spoonful
of coconut oil in my mouth
does it do anything no it doesn't it
called oil pulling it's good for teeth
whitening and battling cavities and you
how he's and I have though well I just
started doing this yeah I like keeping
things simple and easy
she's like the fast food drive-thru
method of makeup convenience consistency
I don't do my makeup until I get to work
nice I think I got the [ __ ] out of the
bargain
your morning is just harder in every way
I don't know how I'm gonna I may just
die I don't really know why I would use
coconut oil I think I have pretty good
oral hygiene already I just pulled into
my 6:10 a.m. class it wasn't as bad as I
thought it would be it was like I was
too tired to feel tired if that makes
any sense I didn't look up how much
coconut oil is supposed to put in my
mouth but here we go this is what it
looks like that looks really really
gross got my bag of chips showed up it's
crazy to me to think that being junk
food right after working out is like
part of her routine and it's kind of
satisfying so Jen left me a little
surprise makeup blush with some wetness
this is something I've never even
noticed I don't really know what I'm
trying to replicate here okay oh [ __ ]
that's a lot like I look like like a
Bond villain right now it didn't taste
that bad kind of liked it
okay now I got my nerves put above
lashes as I supposed to I'm gonna brush
my teeth because it was really sweet my
mom saw me in the beauty anything sugar
you gotta brush your teeth so I miss
where's like the magic makeup eraser oh
that's what I need right now
I was surprised at how thick coconut oil
is it gets thicker cuz it's like taking
up the toxins from your mouth really
yeah okay I had no idea what I was doing
with that thing it was delicious though
when I first saw him I couldn't stop
laughing
I just felt ashamed and embarrassed why
I try to write new you know for work and
I just was like this is gibberish and
said I had to take a nap at like 9:15
I'm out of time I had to do everything
was really satisfying I think that
there's definitely something I've
learned from this where there's like
other good things you can extract from
other people's routines like for
instance coconut oil seems like a good
thing that is a huge concession because
he hated that coconut oil well I hate it
cuz they can't talk to Sofia so here's
the solution we do it at the same time
it's definitely a weird feeling to just
like start eating junk food immediately
after like having one of the hardest
workouts of your life but it was also
really
satisfying to